[Music]
the main objective of my proposal is
freely to to raise awareness amongst the
European parliamentarians not only the
parliamentarians but the decision-makers
it has to come to the to the council to
the Commission to the public what's
going on and where our arms are are used
they criterias they are rather good
already but the problem is that the
countries they do not fulfill them in
the end we want to open a discussion on
on making a change when it comes to the
human rights criteria all countries they
are selling arms Saudi Arabia the
situation for human rights we all know
how it is
but according to the actual criteria
it's totally fine to sell Raider systems
or submarines or things like that and
there is also a demand from the public
opinion then we cannot continue to sell
arms to Saudi Arabia we propose now to
have embargoes we remind about the
embargo we already proposed in the
European Parliament against Saudi Arabia
but we would like to be that to be
extended to other what authoritarian
States also and then we have a big
industry of course and daily they have a
lot of high technology that we can need
for other threats that we are facing in
this moment we have the cyber threats we
have climate change
I don't do understand that there are a
lot of people working there but I
believe also that people in the industry
they want to be proud of what are you
doing are you proud if you know that
what you are doing are killing people in
other countries I don't think so
you